she's uh she's a doctor she's a
psychiatrist
and this the scientific uh primary
peer-reviewed literature
bro why are you laughing
sorry this man looks like he just died
for our sins
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen bro damn bro
i wasn't gonna laugh and then he laughed
and oh i couldn't hold it in
no what happened just the voice crack
yo uh i slept two eyes last night
and my voice does that one bro it was
just it was so
perfect bro i loved it this is what it
is bro but
but just because it's t3m bro for y'all
we ain't gonna start again
unless you get it done as i was saying
before
this man choked in his own piece
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to the
t3m podcast
today we are going to be talking about
jin jin kind shaytan
and imma let romney steal the floor for
now all right just
so before there was man before we
existed before our ancestors existed
before adam alaihissalam
there was a creation named the jinn the
jinn kind
and people might say okay these are
demons or they're ghosts or like all
this stuff but
they're jin and we're going to talk
about what they are so the same way
we are created from clay from dirt
and other things in the quran but mainly
dirt is what we're made of right that's
what allah that's like the the main
thing that people usually talk about
we come from there we go back to their
so on and so forth the jinn are made
from a smokeless fire
right they're made from a smokeless fire
and allah created them first and they
allah created them similar to us in the
sense that they have free will
they could choose to do what they want
to do and so on and so forth and they
were put on the earth before we were
so with the jinn there were you know
prophets and messengers and people that
were sent from the jain and
that as far as i know i believe they're
you know people sent uh and there are
good ones and bad ones because with free
will you have good and bad
there's also neutral ones right um what
do you mean by neutral
like good bad and neutral
i don't know ones that are neither good
nor bad bro they're just they're just
out here doing them
yeah this man said what do you mean by
that you said good
bad and neutral
um to be honest i mean would you say
that mankind could be good bad or
neutral
in the same way yeah okay then if you
look at it like that then i guess you
could say but i mean
it's up to a lot to end the day to judge
who's actually good who's actually bad
but my point is they do good they can do
bad they can do more
more good than bad or they can do more
bad than good i think it's really hard
to have a perfectly equal amount of good
and bad
um because allah knows best at the end
of the day um
but yeah so they had their their wars
and their problems and their issues and
all that
and they cause mischief and corruption
on the earth and problems and all of
that
and then later on later on and this is
where we're moving into iblis actually
let me talk about iblees first because
iblis was one of the jinn
we mentioned i think before he's one of
the gen and he was basically the
the best of the best of the jinn he was
the highest he was the greatest of the
jinn because he obeyed allah
to like the absolute highest
potential he had and allah raised him
to the ranks of the angels allah allah
be in jannah in heaven with the angels
rather than on earth and over time you
know he was he was the big cat
right he was the big dog he had that
arrogance to him but it didn't come out
until later on
until allah announced that he will uh
put
another creation on the earth
and he created the body of adam and i
salaam
and now atleast is beginning to think
like what the hell you know it's like
it's like a child
when another child is born they're like
the hell is that thing
right they're going to get more
attention than me all of a sudden and
all this stuff so
iblis is looking at adamus and before he
had life he was just a body
and he he goes he like goes around him
and he's like
you know knocking on his body and going
through it and in and out and observing
him and seeing what he's all about and
seeing he's made from dirt
and all this stuff um and then allah
gives life to adam alaihissalam
and he commands all the angels and
everyone in the heavens so that includes
iblis to prostrate
to adam out of respect obviously for
allah's new creation
and allah says everyone about all the
angels everybody bowed except iblis
and then allah asked like why did you
disobey basically he has why do you
disobey
and he says i'm better than him you made
me from fire you made him from dirt
i'm not going to prostrate to someone
like that and he disobeyed allah and
that and it was arrogance right it was
ingratitude and arrogance that he had
and then allah said you're expelled
you're you know you're an accursed
person you're expelled get down from
here
and then um he made the promise to show
that
humans mankind are ungrateful the same
way he was
right they're not um pause there was
something
this is
you said you froze and then fire was
like pausing you literally just stayed
there bro
all right listen listen listen i was
gonna throw under something beautiful
there that allah
was like were you always ungrateful
and what i'm gonna let you i'm gonna let
you say it because you're the one that
taught me that bro
he said um i'll talk about the opposite
of arrogance in a bit uh but
allah asked did you just become arrogant
or were you always proud were you always
arrogant did it just happen now or did
you always have it with you
and that's the thing it's like obviously
it's something that developed over time
did i freeze again or what nah bro i'm
just laughing at what this man said
i literally said boss bro and you lagged
for like 15 seconds
i thought it was man i thought it was
good to be honest i didn't even realize
a lot that's how i am but that's that's
a t3m highlight right there inshallah
but uh you gotta you gotta put your
glasses on bro that's why
um you started slipping after that eh
yeah yeah
man they're gonna be like this man just
waits for like half of the episode and
just puts it in
man
are those actual glasses or are those
like the blue light glasses blue light
glasses yeah
i see usb all right so back to the story
bismillah before i freeze again
uh so yeah allah asks
were you always arrogant or did you just
become proud did you just become
arrogant
and obviously this is something that
built up over all the time he was up
there and had that status because
or maybe it's the mummy yeah my bad i
just started laughing at the same thing
i was laughing at bro go ahead continue
continue go continue are you sure you
want to get it off
[Music]
yo why don't we just delete our whole
youtube channel just for animal's sake
let's just start filming every single
episode again bro let's do it good idea
we'll start the channel over as the
three giants
bismillah this is man bro ah [ __ ] i know
i mean
romney take it away bro take it away all
right all right
so for the third time hopefully last
time
this man really said three giants bro
hey why'd you make an instagram group
chat and call it the three giants bro
knowing we already have an instagram
group chat yeah oh
bro i don't know are you around i love
you guys bro
i'll give you my word this is final go
in bro
yeah mute bro mute yourself i'm gonna
mute myself bros i'm gonna make a fool
out of myself
all right all right bismillah so
third time inshallah
all right for the third time insha'allah
allah asks did you just become arrogant
or were you always arrogant were you
always proud
bismillah and obviously this is
something that could have developed over
time it could have happened as soon as
he got up there
but when he saw adam alaihi that's when
it actually came out that's when he said
i
am better than him and that's arrogance
that's arrogance because you're
disobeying allah
because of something you think what's
the matter with you and then he
actually makes a prayer to allah he
prays to allah despite
you know being in that disobedient state
he asked allah
at least like you know preserve me until
the day of of
uh judgment and allah said you will be
preserved until the appointed time
basically until the trumpets blown and
everything else is is uh
dead after and allah
in a way accepts the dua of iblees
because that's what allah will that's
what
allowed and then he has this promise
it's eternal not eternal but as long as
we're alive this promise to misguide us
except for the chosen few of allah who
are actually good indeeds who are
actually good people
that receive the reward of allah
and those who are actually grateful to
allah and that's basically how iblis the
jinn
became shaitaan the jinn and from then
generation by generation person to
person he and his little shayateen
because there's the shaitaan the ibly
shaitaan and then his little his little
devils
that go in and try and get people off
the path and it's just been
entire all of mankind now shaitaan has
been trying to misguide us
and again as we mentioned he is from
amongst the gen kind
yo question for you bro how long how
long these dudes live
man or is this dude just gonna be alive
for the rest of time until
it's the day of judgment until not until
the day of judgment but until
uh allah commands the angel islam to
blow the horn
which is starting like basically the day
of judgment or
like basically the first time the horn
is blown everything dies
and i believe shaytan will die as well
that's the appointed time
and then the horn is blown again
everything will come back and he will
come back again and then he will be
judged just like everybody else
but this dude is still kicking it yeah
fourteen hundred even more than fourteen
hundred years and he's still kicking it
tens of thousands of years maybe even
hundreds of thousands allahu adam
because
we're alive before mankind was so
apparently there's three times as many
as humans really mm-hmm
damn all right
yeah man speaking of jen as much as we
want to go in
personal experiences aside
some of y'all might have let me say that
let me say real quick before you even go
in
let me say what i had said before we
started the podcast
and that is if anyone's like wanting us
to go in on the details
of like gender experiences i've had gin
experiences
fire has had gin experiences rami has
had homosexual experiences not negen
experiences but some homosexual
experiences
um a lot of by the way
it was all mental not physical um
we can't explain or we cannot not
explain but we can't say the details and
the reason for that
is because even though
we are not in that state anymore because
when you experience a gin encounter
i go as far as to say that like
that's your vibration that's your
frequency that's like bringing that in
like if you're afraid
if you're weak you're going to literally
be the odd one now it's like if there's
a
a pack of animals there's a lion hunting
these animals
the lion's gonna go after the straggler
the one that's lagging behind the weak
one the one that's like out in the open
that's vulnerable so if someone has an
experience like this
is because you were in a vulnerable
place and while you may not be in that
place anymore
when you're saying the details of the
time where you had that experience
that's not only bringing you back into
that state of being
but it's also bringing everyone else
who's listening to you into that state
of being
it's like when we were kids and we would
hear a scary story or a ghost story
and it would just make us that much more
scared
that much more susceptible and just what
we start seeing and hearing things
so for that sake we're not gonna get
into details but before
i even continue my rant fired continue
bro hi bismillah my name is any of y'all
peeps that have had any type of
experiences with gin encounters
again you don't need to tell us about it
just know
if you have had in the past if you're
currently going through anything
or if in the future you do let me give
you guys some
scientific literature on this all right
i will definitely post
i know we always say this but we never
do your feedback has been heard
p3m so i will link it in the description
this actual study
if i don't comment down below and remind
me but i highly doubt it's going to
happen this time
anyway bismuth so there's been a study
conducted by
um some ladies she's a phd she's a a
muslim uh
i'm pretty sure she's uh she's a doctor
she's a psychiatrist
and this the scientific uh primary
peer-reviewed literature
bro why are you laughing
sorry this man looks like he just died
for our sins
yo why why you had to put it like that
bro
you're gonna hurt all the christians bro
i thought it was not
if she's yeah you know damn well there
ain't no christians watching this
anyway there's a few there's a few yeah
i see one right now bro
um and i think it was called uh rookia
and jin treatment or jin uh possession
treatment and i shared this with brother
rami a couple months ago a couple weeks
ago
so yeah rami you know remind me go a
little bit into rokia
and exorcisms and all of that in a bit
after i'm done
on has done i still don't know what this
man is doing bro
but anyway
okay cool in
mute yourself man fire is trying to talk
bro and then you just
jump there you're like all right [ __ ]
be like look
honey i'm sorry all right all right all
right listen
no i'm not gonna mute myself go ahead we
got
in this physical dimension just speaking
about chemistry we got ions
all right so an ion we got atoms atoms
have
a specific charge it's a neutral charge
right not positive not negative
ion just means all the electrons it has
it either has a surplus or a deficit if
it has a surplus
it has a negative charge and it's called
an anion if it has a positive charge it
has a deficit
and it's called a cation now don't worry
too much about what these names are
bear with me so jin based on this
scientific literature that this this um
this doctor posted the psychiatrist
posted she found out
there were a ton of different key
takeaways from this
and a lot of y'all can definitely get
value from this and may allah
help guide you to utilize these and
protect you from gen kind
let's go into it so jin love
and they absolutely love positively
charged ions
so they love cations anytime you have
anything like a tv
electronics radio equipment static
appliances
phones laptops they have a current their
electronics
so electric like electrons are busy
doing that thing they got a surplus of
positively charged anions or positively
charged ions which are cations
and you got jin chaitan chatting they
love that so they're gonna flock to this
all right
so they love things like this they love
alcohol
they love things like tight clothes
spaces they love
air conditioning they love um heating
anything like that that's not natural so
hvac all right they absolutely hate
anything that has negative charge ions
so atoms they cannot stand that
so from my experiences without getting
too in depth
how i got my room i'm not gonna say how
i got all the gin out of my room bro
um while there's john was over here
hanging out how i got that was
i got myself this thing called a
himalayan salt
lamp or a pink salt lamp y'all have
probably seen it
i think anna has had some experience
with one and uh
i got two in my house and it's just a
normal pink salt lamp
and what happens is when you put a light
light bulb
the light bulb heats up the salt the
rock salt and that literally
ionizes the crystals and the
metal mineral ions on the surface this
man bro
continue and you got that you got that
just dispersed dispense into the air
and you got a negative negative ions
um surrounding now you got a lot of
interesting studies co-studies from this
you got people saying
oh use of negative iron treatment or
pink salt lamp
increases happiness increases subjective
well-being includes increases
satisfactory um subjective uh i guess
effect it increases positivity ah bro it
just takes away these gin
but they don't know any better so you
got these things that that
completely removed gin i did this it
completely made my room cool
another thing to hate um aside from
negative anions which are found in
these um using himalayan salt lamps
they hate the environment after a
thunderstorm
so if you guys can think of an
environment right after a rainbow
i look at romney bro this man's trying
extra hard to hold it in bro
i know he's trying to just just lose it
all again but we probably won't
bro you've never looked more puerto
rican let me just get that out there
oh romney
you bro i look puerto rican right now
that's cause i am puerto rican
i bro you were putting up your hands
like you wanted to fight i was like bro
i am
not near you i cannot fight you right
now i thought you're coming to
toronto bro yeah i am soon bro i'll get
my tickets so i can fight you
i can break romney's ankles bro
damn i'm literally humiliation bro i'm
literally coming to toronto
to show both y'all look
yo i'ma start a gofundme just for this
i bet all right let's get back to it
guys i think he dropped the show
sorry so nah bro you good bro
so those are some of the things click
the link down below read that
peer-reviewed journal article find out
some things here and there but
rookia is basically an exorcism where
you get
gin chatting all of them out once
they've already done a possession of
your body
and you are possessed with these gin so
once you do it okay
they found tremendous findings and guys
this isn't something like
brown auntie saying this this is
literally like a psychiatrist this is a
peer-reviewed
american medical association journal
article
and there's been cases with infertility
where couples couldn't have a kid and
they were trying to be expecting but
they couldn't conceive
and after doing rookia treatment what do
you know bro they conceived
easily and these are these are couples
that have been trying for i think
upwards of 15 plus
years which is nuts and it goes to show
that they really got in the way
of that a couple other things that is
worth noting aside from electronics and
things they love
and close spaces hvac they really love
blood
just let me put out there
hmm particularly menstrual blood
that's what i said in the in the in the
article it's not another one
also goes to show why um
performing the natural obligation when a
girl has honor menzies
is impermissible i'm not saying x equals
y but you guys know what i mean
yeah but hold up clarify it for the
women's
watching this because they're probably
going to be like
i have my period once a month does this
mean that i am susceptible
that you are clarified why don't you go
a little more in the detail
before i was gonna say no you're all
susceptible 24 7.
no this is a this is a ps8 everyone man
just at the end of the day we're all
susceptible 24 7 but as angel said
the biggest thing we can do is not lower
our vibration
and more i guess terms i would use
is the more you fear anything jin shut
down anything
the more it'll be easier for them to
take control of you
because fear takes you off your side and
takes you up your square it takes you
off
being grounded in your logic so you are
more susceptible
to influence through your subconscious
by those means
thanks bro there was um
on instagram
i forgot this um i forgot her name
she she's a sister she no no this isn't
sonia bro
we're not talking about this i'm talking
about like a legitimate
she's a a sister in the faith and she
was um
mia were talking about this and
i had basically said that like you can't
be afraid basically what you just said
right now you can be afraid
it lowers your vibrational state lowers
your state of being it makes you more
susceptible
and it's like ultimately genders are
real
you know like if you believe in the
creator
if you believe in the quran if you
believe in the sunnah if you believe in
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
then you must believe in jinns because
they are written
in there they are spoken about in there
and it's like
yeah suppose we don't hear anything good
from the gins or about the gins i should
say
but that doesn't mean you should fear
them at the end of the day you already
know who you should feel
that's it bro
only the creator y'all take it away
y'all muted both of you
oh stay muted that's cool i mean if i'm
going to jump in here
inshallah there's actually it's not just
when you're angry it's also when you're
sexually aroused and when you're sad and
i believe there's one other state that
i'd slip in my mind but there are videos
on this inshallah
i believe it's in islamic literature as
well and there was like forced
times when you're like really
susceptible i think so when you're
sexually aroused when you're sad
when you're scared um there's another
one i slip in my mind now but
there's a number of them so
in islam like you mentioned fire is uh
exorcism
but the way it's conducted is is by the
i mean there are different methods and
different
tools that they use but essentially
they're reciting quran right they're
saying the words of allah
and this is to exercise or to get rid of
the the jinn that possess a person
that's like attaching themselves to a
person
this not the other and the thing is not
only should we not be scared of them but
we should know that we're actually
stronger than them
we're actually stronger than the uh than
the jinn
and people think that oh they can
possess us and
we can't see them so we don't know where
they are or what's happening and
none of this matters at the end of the
day because they actually
they're they're very weak compared to us
and they can only come at us in very
specific states
right when we're in very specific states
or we're especially susceptible when
we're in specific states
and if you seek refuge and protection
from allah
like reciting uh surah al-falaq
it is basically seeking refuge in allah
against the the creation that which
lingers in the darkness
um from the evil they may plot and also
from the uh
um envy and from evil eye
and people who like blow knots and do
black magic and that stuff so recite
that it's very easy it's short to
memorize very easy
um and a lot of the time when someone
does rocket shurian themselves
they recite surah fatiha ayatollah
and the um the last three chapters of
the quran
what i just mentioned and surah annas
and this is insha allah
sufficient enough to protect you um or
to even get rid of jin
if they're bothering you i'll say she
had mentioned that
she had mentioned that and i had someone
else mention as well
um i think you said it but sooner or
did you say that yeah yeah yeah yeah
that one
but yeah y'all y'all shouldn't be afraid
of the gins i mean
jen's over here possessing and
you know you can do the exorcism is so
like that but bro
we should flip the script we should be
the ones possessing the gems
like let's start a gofundme for that man
let's start
a whole movement where we actually start
possessing the gents
i'm done bro and at the end of the day
like it just goes to show you take that
back bro
that's that's we can't possess this man
when you look at when you look at human
beings bro
mankind can hurt us too you could damn
well step outside and get shot but
you're not here dwelling on that but
you're dying on jinn
both of them have free will both of them
are creations of allah
you already know what to do but kind of
ironic i didn't know that but in jannah
if there are any jinn that will make it
to jenna it's going to be
flipped and they cannot see us and we
get to see them
hmm mommy didn't know about that did you
it's the first time i'm hearing about it
yeah we'll go and take them glasses off
and you'll understand
what's up but um in in the in the holy
quran allah says that uh
oh mankind can see you from where you
cannot see them
but they can see you from where you
cannot see them and
it just it's not like allah is talking
about like oh they're like in that
little corner
uh in your little crevice in your
bookshelf where you think there's
someone i'm not trying to scare you guys
out of here um it's not like physically
they're there but they're here
but they're not of these three
dimensions so that's why you know we
can't see them but in general if they
don't make it inshallah
when we get there um we get to see them
bro
probably from where they cannot see us
and they cannot see us
now before we go in if anal doesn't have
anything out to this
rami go straight into this black magic
witchcraft
what is this man i know it's one of
these major sins but before
properly you know coming into islam
having full firm conviction
i thought this was just a hoax i don't
believe in all this
voodoo and witchcraft yeah so actually
to summarize it because people are
they have like weird understandings of
black magic black magic is using the
jinn
it's using the jin to do haram so let's
say ajin wants to possess a person
okay they go if they're able to they
possess a person
let's say a human is in contact with the
jinn and they send the jinn to go ruin
someone's life
make things harder for them give the you
know
taint them mentally or or otherwise
right because they can also cause mental
illnesses and that stuff i think that's
in the uh
article you refer that's in the article
so the article also says on the side
note romney that
all of these mental illnesses that we
see today the whole spectrum
is caused by jin to lesser a greater
extent and degree
all right um
so yeah basically black magic is using
the jinn
to do haram and allah says in the quran
that they sold
themselves their soul their life their
hereafter for a miserable price for
literally nothing
for nothing they're like they're ripping
themselves off basically
throwing it all away it's not for allah
and it's haram because it's it like it
obviously it ruins people's lives and
there's no justice when it comes to that
except for in the hereafter when allah
punishes you
for it but um basically there's a few
methods they do i've heard some really
weird things
um from like voodoo dolls to like
cutting off a chicken's head and doing
some weird stuff and
um i even heard something like they use
your nails like your fingernails
if they can get a hold of your
fingernails or hair and they have they
want to conduct that it's a wrap for you
yeah yeah they can take things that um
they can give you things
that are are like um we'll call it curse
they'll give you things that they did
something to
and if it's in your possession it could
you know uh
basically have the gin come to you
basically uh they could take anything
that you own
like like you said nails and hair and
that stuff um as far as i know
and they can do a whole bunch of weird
stuff and this is haram and it's
it it makes you a disbeliever no matter
what you think say or believe this makes
you
a disbeliever it makes you a kafir and
you will be punished for this
horribly it's one of the worst things in
islam
i mean
yeah what's crazy is that if someone
does
like magic bro like
they're not just like let's say they're
trying to curse someone they're trying
to set a curse on someone
let's say they're successful let's say
they do get a gin
to actually make this person's life a
living hell
bro their life isn't the only one that's
going to be a living hell
like the person who made the curse the
person who
got the jinns help in the first place
bro they're going to be cursed
as well they're gonna have a living hell
in this world and in the next bro
and like i'm not gonna say i'm not gonna
say names here
but i know some people
i know some people who they were
together
and the male
ended up cheating on the female she had
kids
okay they had kids together yo why you
gotta air out romney's dirty laundry bro
yeah no bro for real for this we'll talk
about talking about
all right so and i'm keeping names out
because i want to be respectful
to the people who are in this story okay
so you have this man
and this woman they had kids together
the man cheats on the woman
all right now when this all happened the
woman
felt so much anger and so much hatred
towards the man
that she actually went with her mom to
uh
what would you guys call them what would
you classify them a black magician
it sounds like some yu-gi-oh stuff
y'all remember yugioh
a side note i almost went to jail for
yu-gi-oh bro
what yeah cause um
um let's just say they uh
they caught me doing something that was
haram
and uh for like a better words out
stealing
and i almost went to jail for that i was
stealing cards bro oh my god
i was trying to get all the best cards
but
anyways what would y'all call the people
who like
practice them like black magicians
witch doctors witches witches
all right so the woman goes with her
mother
bro that's a witch in spanish but um the
woman goes with her mother
to this buddha and she basically
has the bruha set a curse on the man
all right so like like romney said this
is
gins these are gins that are actually
being
uh called upon to work here and it's
crazy because i've seen this video on
youtube
where this guy was like explaining it
perfectly where it's like
the bruja the witch the person who's
conducting the curse
will literally like have to gather like
a whole bunch of different things
throughout like a span of a few days and
will also make the person that's like
wanting to get the curse set on
so-and-so person
will make them either acquire certain
things or do
something that's humiliating and it's
like at the end of that whole thing
yes the gin is doing what uh
what the um the the bruja is making the
jin do
but the one submitting to the brewer or
the one submitting to the jinn
is the brewer and the person that's
asking the bruja to make the curse
bro why are you laughing because that's
i keep saying bruja
yes sir yo but real talk real talk right
so
you you have the the mother and
this woman they go they go to the blue
her
and they basically ask the blue guy to
set a curse on the man the one who
cheated on her
all right so for the next
20 years all right for the next
20 years this man has
had nothing but bad things happen
in his life i and
like i said i'm not going to say names
or
any details but this guy literally told
me that he's always felt like
after him and that woman
broke up that like there was this black
this black cloud i was gonna say black
nouveau which is cloud in spanish but
like this black cloud over his head
what you laughing at bro that's my
native tongue i was thinking you know
how we're gonna write
gin witchcraft x's whatever in the topic
we'll just i don't know
spanish lessons yes yes yeah yes
so he told me that for like the past 20
years he had been experiencing
almost like this black cloud over his
head where it's like
anything that was bad that could happen
would happen
and then what's crazy is that the woman
actually had
a very brief period of time where
she felt good she felt free she felt
happy
but yo what do they say when it's like
when
uh this is a side note here but what do
they say when like you quote unquote
sell your soul to the devil it's like he
gives you
temporary uh gratification temporary
rewards
uh temporary happiness something like
that and then he strips it away from you
because it was it was an illusion it
wasn't real
to begin with right and bro like this
woman
for a few years she felt good only to
then
have that same black cloud that this man
talked about
now she has it too so now bro it's been
going on like
25 26 years
and they still have that same thing that
they're experiencing so look at that
this person wanted to curse this other
person because of what he did
and now this person ended up cursing the
both of them
that's tough man and i ever heard so
really not go on bro
i've heard in islam that um if you curse
somebody and it doesn't fall on them it
falls back on you
it's tough that's scary that's a scary
thought man it is scary bro major l
um all i have to say was bro is bruja
feminine
how do you say a male bro bro
but i mean i've never i've never heard
bruho but i mean i guess you could
technically say brujo
you gotta roll that r
let me hear you roll the r bro
come on bro you speak arabic roll the r
come on bro patreon and only fans link
in the description why are we giving all
these gems away for
for free bro come on man you're teasing
them bro you're making them all wet
i didn't tease them bro but last week
when romney had the he was telling me to
take out the nipple bro that was teasing
what you talking about that was like 30
minutes ago
it was last week for them bro
nah bro they know they know
[Music]
you're standing bro like in the other
video you were also standing in that
same exact position
you know what's funny bro if they're
watching this video and they're probably
like
damn bro they literally filmed two
episodes not even moving no change of
clothes same location
same time and then they watch for the
next three months
it's the same thing and they're like
damn bro how many episodes do they film
coordination right there
[Music]
yes all right romney anything you want
to add to that
whole topic any other terms or topics
or themes that you think are relevant to
this so far we talked about shaitaan
or satan or devil we talked about
sharatheen
jin we talked about a little bit about
witchcraft
black magic kala jadu whatever you want
to call it
um just quickly there's something called
hasad
and hassan is is a type of envy where
you know like you look at someone and
like
we're not talking about us we're talking
about you know low-life
beta pathetic people that look at people
who have good things and
they become envious right like i wish i
had that right
hassan is another level of that it's not
only do i want what you have
but i don't want you to have it i want
to have what you have and i don't want
you to have it i want you to be
like low and pathetic and all this stuff
that's hazard
and i just i don't want to talk about
things i don't know about um i believe
it does have things to do with the jin
it's a disease of the heart that you
have but i believe
um hased actually has like implications
on another person's life
it's called evil eye all right and it's
if you give the person the evil eye
something bad may happen in their life
and you have to do rocky
to get rid of that like the gene are
involved in that as well um but my
knowledge on it stops there so i don't
want to go
any further on that yeah guys nazar is a
real thing
that's the term for evil eye nazir
yeah it's or do hindi bengali whatever
you guys want to do
the d is silent the d is zed
what n a
z a r
[Music]
all right that's all i got man
all right guys
all right get out man i feel like
they're waiting on something for you
i feel like i'm waiting for something
for myself as well
i don't know what it is all right man
this time
we're gonna let you close
i'm gonna close mm-hmm
all right i don't know i don't know bro
i'm gonna put you on blast i'm gonna put
you on blast just like i did before bro
it's beautiful come on bro it is what it
is
bismillah
[Applause]
just staying silent there bro no i was
smiling man it made me happy much like i
know you read mine bro
it just brings joy to my heart bro bro i
was gonna like i was gonna say it in a
rhythm
but you gotta be a little nervous
oh hi guys with that being said
hope you all enjoyed his quran
recitation if you made it this far type
in
surah fatiha until next time it's your
boys t3m
it's not that you can't pray or you
don't need to pray
be straight up be honest be a man be a
woman say with your chest you don't want
to pray
and that's okay to feel like that
sometimes but you have to understand
that's a problem
as we always say the biggest problem a
person can have is not knowing they have
a problem to begin with
as long as you acknowledge it's an issue
then you can start to work on it